PTP I was always kind of racist but now
he's a hero to the Nazis wait a minute
no you changed and come on media what
are you doing what does it say now Peter
pies fall shows the limit of Lowell just
kidding
hey all right emigres Ellis may I just
say that if you're gonna call someone a
hero to the Nazis you may want to double
check if that's true or not because
afterwards
you can't go Lowell just kidding
the amount of cherry-picking that the
media came out with after this whole
thing to prove this narrative that I am
somehow an anti-semite
that was beautiful please keep doing it
it's hilarious Vox media posted this on
ironically arguably similar to Nazi
fashion recently he has been wearing
Himmler style glasses and sporting a
fasci slang for fascist Hitler Youth
haircut Vox you got me damn it I didn't
want to admit this I didn't want to talk
about this I love Korean fashion I love
kpop that's why I dyed my hair I'm going
through a midlife crisis here okay I
want to be a kpop star JK Rowling is
calling me a fascist I don't why I guess
she read it on a she read it off a
headline and and sort of went with it
well I read on an online article that
you once said in an interview that you
found dressing up as a Nazi arousing I
read that on an online website so it
must be true right
JK so I made the apology video where I
thought at least was from the heart
explained the situation and I admitted
that I didn't do everything like I'm not
guilt free in this situation by any
means it was it was meant by just the
warmest positivity from the internet and
and anyone that I think saw and it was
just amazing and I owe you
my biggest thanks for all the support
that I got from that video however the
media wasn't as impressed they kind of
stuck with their narrative peopIe
half-heartedly apologizes calls media
[ __ ] PewDiePie's apology for
Nazi jokes shows that it still doesn't
get it
Trump and PewDiePie are using the same
playbook
so we basically went from PewDiePie as a
Nazi to papayas Trump will get there one
day media I'm sure will get there one
day and I want to point out not all
media okay I've seen more and more
balanced articles come out about this
situation even though it seems pretty
dead at this point
the whole situation is a testimony of
old media not understanding YouTube the
[ __ ] senior editor of Wall Street
Journal the senior editor of Wall Street
Journal tweeted mein they Spotify video
is long I'm sorry I'm sorry Mike I'll
try and cut it down next time a little
bit for you so you're not spend so much
time doing your journalist research sigh
oh maybe I'll add a little meme a lot a
little meme and maybe that will make it
more interesting for it for you I don't
I don't know senior editor huh how about
that let's get into the Wall Street
Journal thing there's one thing that I
wanted to talk about that I didn't
really do in my last video which was the
fact that Wall Street Journal went to
the brands that I work with before they
came to me for a comment I know this
because they didn't just talk to Disney
and YouTube it shows to me that they
were just after making the strongest
headline and the strongest story that
they could get without any regards of
what kind of damage they would do in the
process I mean why would why would Wall
Street Journal care about minimizing
harm it's not like it's one of the four
major sections in the journalist code of
ethics I mean why would Wall Street
Journal care about that I don't
understand they wanted that headline
they got the headline Wall Street
Journal should have tried to get a
response from me directly to begin with
not going to brands I worked with first
proves to me they're maliciousness
Christopher mins of the Wall Street
Journal tweeted back at me
demonstrably false but anyway welcome to
our
post truth age he says nothing
absolutely nothing gets printed in The
Wall Street Journal without an attempt
to reach a mentioned subject for comment
so it seems fair right but then he goes
and says I have no idea about the
chronology which was my [ __ ] point
Christopher Mims you demonstrated
yourself false so welcome to the post
truth age the other thing that I had a
problem with was I already brought up I
don't I don't think I need to elaborate
on it which is the context or lack of
context I think in the video there was
one piece of context out of five in
total so if you think that's a balanced
way of doing journalism you tell me I
have a big problem with the whole thing
in general because this whole thing
wasn't a problem until he was brought up
because my audience understand they were
jokes they weren't actually doing anyone
any harm but the way the Wall Street
Journal defended this was that neo-nazi
websites were supporting me calling it
the number one pity pie fansite which I
obviously had no idea about I don't
believe it or not I don't go to neo-nazi
websites The Wall Street Journal
condemns me for using posts they don't
call it jokes they literally says that
the fact that I use Adolf Hitler and the
fact that I use Nazi imagery that's bad
enough
it seems right here that you are guilty
of the same thing oh look there is
Hitler this looks like Nazi imagery to
me someone start the press I think we
have a scoop it turns out the neo-nazi
website have changed their mind
right now they are the number one Wall
Street Journal fan site interesting
I don't believe Wall Street Journal has
made a statement condemning these web
sites so they must be a Nazi supporting
web site now I think we need to talk to
their sponsors about this not Wall
Street Journal themselves or diss
context matter I don't know oh look
here's their sponsors how about that
guess we need to talk to them first
I realize how childish I sound okay it's
just to illustrate this
point and if you didn't think it could
be any more unethical or any more stupid
one of the journalists been fritz it
came out that he's been doing the same
kind of jokes say it's not true he has a
hard-on for the Nazis he wants to fry
the Jews I don't even I don't even want
to show these jokes I don't show
anti-semitic imagery on my channel
that's disgusting I'm so disappointed in
you Ben fritz
I didn't want to say this because it
didn't feel necessary but there wasn't
just pressure to get my show canceled
along with other brands that I work with
that they reached out to YouTube also
had pressure and to de monetize my
entire channel essentially getting me
fired
luckily my videos does not go against
Community Guidelines so it didn't but
they tried so it seems only fair by wall
street journal's own way of conducting
themself that ben fritz should get fired
this whole thing has been embarrassing
it's been a fiasco it doesn't make me
happy when i find like these things out
it makes me sad that this is the world
we live in where people people make
articles about people making jokes that
they make themselves trying to get their
lives ruined a thing that i saw a lot on
the media was that because I said Wall
Street Journal did this attack on me and
people just didn't believe me like what
what does the Wall Street Journal has to
gain from that or there there's such a
different organization like they have
nothing to do with what I do so it
wouldn't make any sense well here's a
graph showing that trust in media going
down based on age I assume that pieces
like this is not helping with that
here's a graph of the newspaper ad
revenue from digital imprint showing
decrease of revenue in the media
okay so Wall Street is losing influence
and income hmm I wonder who's gaining
that right now so what does Wall Street
Journal has to gain from doing a piece
like this on me nothing nothing
obviously I mean why else would they put
the article behind a paywall
twice so
Street Journal is losing revenue maybe
maybe I should buy The Wall Street
Journal
actually I don't know it seems like a
failing business to mean convex Tomatoes
ban
[Laughter]
[Music]